obviously you and nip's relationship was
uh you know a great one one that was
very important to hip hop um
you guys put out incredible records
together you guys were peers for
i feel like you guys kind of
career-wise were parallel to each other
the whole time um what was it about nip
from the jump that you guys just kind of
saw each other as this you know like
he's one of me you know what i'm saying
like um he built the same way just the
neighborhood you know i'm saying where
nip comes from i know that area well you
know lamert park is down the street you
know this is all actual factuals not
just rap you know and uh we got a lot of
the same homies and knew a lot of the
same people coming up i didn't know nip
growing up but immediately when i saw
him
you know doing what he was gonna do in
the music business i understood it
because i had that type of heart as well
you know i had that type of heart as
well and i knew that immediately upon
discovering him that um this was
somebody that i was gonna work with and
you know our
our um
our careers would be intertwined in a
way you know and i chose and i chose to
make it a good story you know
immediately even before i met him you
know um and so you know just meeting him
i thought like you know he was brilliant
he was serious about what he was going
to do i could tell that at a young age
and i and the most important thing i
love was the structure of the business i
love you know
black sam you know
panichi you know household names j-rock
you know fats rest in peace you know
these was like copy supreme these was
like people that he really loved and
worked with and they all respected each
other and i thought that
i wanted my friends and my family to see
that because that's what i wanted you
know i wanted us to be and eventually we
had separate crews he had all money in i
have opm but you know when we got
together it was always like a family
thing you know we had shows together
where
you know his family will be selling
merch my family will be selling merch
simple as that you know trading secrets
side by side on you know new
technologies and things like that things
that people never really saw right you
know and that was like those were the
most important things to me you know i
mean to be there for him when
he was trying to make something of his
career when people maybe didn't believe
in it but i knew how talented and how
special that he was for sure it's just
you ha it's an art to to this all you
know and trying to get people to feel
that through music is not easy you know
no it's definitely i feel like you guys
are always going to be synonymous with
each other
in terms of just the classic record
y'all got yeah for sure and i just feel
like
you know out of la
from like 2010 on like you guys were
built for the longevity like if you
think about all the artists that came up
during that area obviously it's kendrick
j-rock but yeah but you guys kind of i
feel like
you guys kind of embody ownership yeah
[ __ ] accountability yeah for sure
accountability we used to talk about it
a lot you know it was worse that was
thrown around you know and
the great thing about it is now we
inspired a lot of artists that's out
right now doing their thing and
that's the most incredible part is that
all those times that we were sitting
around trying to make songs and inspire
people and you know find our fans and
our voices and it's like now people
really appreciate it you know and we
probably didn't get that then and we
wasn't in it for the glory or the credit
immediately so it didn't really matter
but i think the beautiful thing is like
all the artists that's out right now
that's having their career having a way
with it was the ones that was inspired
and listening to the things that we was
putting out you know when we was doing
our thing